Speaker 1: You know, the phrase sometimes
a little bit of knowledge is a dangerous thing,
it really applies to a clip we're going to
look at today of Laura Trump.
That's Eric Trump's wife, Donald Trump's daughter
in law, and now a Fox News contributor.
We're going to look at video of Laura Trump
saying she's against covid precautions because
she gets really happy.
She's thrilled when her children get sick.
Now, the context of all of this is that because
of the explosive spread of the virus, again,
because of the Delta variant, particularly
among unvaccinated people, places around the
country are saying masks are coming back on.
Some increasingly employers are saying you're
going to need to be vaccinated in order to
work here.
Remember that Fox News has a set of rules
in place where if you're not vaccinated and
you haven't proven your vaccination through
a portal that FOX has, which is like a vaccine
passport, you have to keep wearing masks when
you work at Fox News, etc..
So this is happening on Fox and FOX is doing
a lot of this stuff.
Laura Trump says a whole bunch of different
things that make no sense whatsoever and that
she's thrilled when her children get sick.
So let's take a look.
Let's take a vaccinated Americans.
Speaker 2: Fox News contributor Laura Trump
is here to react to that.
Good morning.
I know you have two school age children.
How do you feel about the children under the
age of 12 will have to wear a mask again,
right?
Well, I think it's absolutely ludicrous.
First of all, we know the efficacy of masks
have been long disputed.
It was Dr. Fauci who a year and a half ago,
I remember, told us all, if it makes you feel
better, wear a mask.
But remember,
Speaker 1: that was this is what how many
months in are we now?
17, 18 months in for a couple weeks to prevent
a run on masks.
Dr. Fauci and others did not come out and
say, wear a mask.
Then we learn more.
And the consensus among the medical community
has been mostly unchanged for all.
But those first couple of weeks,
Speaker 2: we didn't have to wear a mask.
Originally, he said it wasn't going to really
do anything.
Oh, come on.
And they told us masks and they said three
masks.
They've gone back and forth on this.
But as it relates to kids, I mean, I can tell
you it is almost impossible for my three year
old son to keep a mask on.
So the idea that these kids are going to have
to sit through an entire day in a classroom
with masks on, you see the video.
Speaker 1: This has real I'd like to speak
to the manager vibes guys.
I have to tell you,
Speaker 2: the kids who were waiting for the
bus crying because they don't want to have
to wear the mask and give them headaches from
a social perspective, they can't see the faces
of the other children.
We know also if we're following the science
and they like we were supposed to do the entire
time.
But thank goodness children do not get covered
in the same way that adults do if they get
it.
We know that they get a very mild case of
They're not the super spreaders that we originally
were told they might be.
And so the idea that we were going to make
our children sit in school masked up all day
long, I think is absolutely ludicrous.
They're also not coming in contact with germs
that they need to develop an immune system.
My daughter, Carolina, last week had a cold.
Every parent knows that's a nightmare.
I have to tell you, I was so thrilled because
I know that she is actually getting in contact
with viruses and germs and bacteria that will
allow her to develop an immune system.
This is absolutely insane that we are considering.
Speaker 1: So this is another person who can't,
first of all, can't understand.
You might consider someone other than just
your kid because Carolina Trump or whatever
the kid's name is, it when it because it's
thrilling to her that her kid got a cold.
That's not a reason to say no masks for kids
at all, even as this is spreading uncontrollably
and the issue isn't kids building up their
immune system against the flu or against germs.
The point here is to keep people from getting
covid-19, which is a deadly infectious disease
that can kill some people.
It can land some people in the hospital.
But even for people that it doesn't make very
sick, they can pass it and then infect others
and possibly kill others.
She doesn't seem to understand that.
She can't think about anybody other than maybe
herself in her own immediate family, which
seems to run in the Trump family.
If you guys have noticed and by the way, you
don't have to get sick to develop immunity.
You know, this idea that if you're not getting
sick, you're not developing immunity.
We have things called vaccines, which her
kids will hopefully soon be able to get even
at their ages if she'll go and get them vaccinated.
And there is some truth very broadly to the
idea that you don't want to keep your kids
in a bubble if they have zero exposure from
the time they're kids to anything from a very
young age.
There are some studies that show that that
can be problematic.
That's not what's been discussed here.
It's not what's being discussed.
Larry Trump's kids have been out in the world
this entire time up until the pandemic and
wearing a mask at school, which, by the way,
you.
We'll get germs on your hands and then later
you're out on the playground and there's dirt
and there's different things and you're around
Don Jr.'s kids and all this different stuff,
just wearing the mask at school for a few
months is not going to do whatever it is she
thinks it's going to do to their immune system.
It's absolutely nuts, but not as nuts as this
next clip.